in today's episode of lunch and earn
we're going to talk about chaos vs order
if you have too much order in your
business and in your life you're going
to get bored and if you have too much
chaos in your life on your business
you're going to start to go crazy and
for every person there's this line that
you have to figure out how much chaos
and how much order do I need in order to
be happy to be productive to be creative
and live my best life possible I'm
constantly changing up my schedule my
routine because I get bored easily i
don't know if i have a DD or if that's
just something being an entrepreneur you
like to have variety and creativity but
what i found is that when i feel like i
have i'm doing the same thing for too
long too many days in a row I crave
variety i need to add something new into
it and if i stop doing that then i'll be
unhappy I feel like it won't be creative
and I crave that and I think too many
people this is most of the world I don't
think it's so much believe nation
because you guys are entrepreneurs and
you're watching this channel for a
reason but most of the world they're
stuck in a pattern of too much order of
too much boredom and they go and they
work these jobs for their entire life
and they're living for the weekends and
the evenings because that's the only
time they get to be creative and so if
you find yourself in that kind of rut
where there's too much order and you're
bored you have to find a way to do
something different to add a little bit
more chaos into your business in your
life so you will be happier at the same
time you can have too much chaos in your
life and that makes you want to go crazy
and you're not getting any of your
projects done and you feel like you're
just being mediocre at everything
instead of focusing your efforts and I
went through this recently where my team
created a whole bunch of different
templates for what I can do with the
website new landing pages new homepage
design all these various site types of
pages for the website and I just felt
overwhelmed and if all I was doing was
the website that would be fine I could
handle it but I'm doing the youtube
channel and answering your comments and
working on brand deals and write in my
book and acquired a company and now i'm
working on their website and working
with their team there's a lot that's on
my plate there's a lot on my head right
now I'm feeling more stretch than I've
ever felt in my life and and looking at
that list all the different things to do
with the website I just felt too of
whelmed and I connected with Jason who's
on my team and we went out for crepes to
talk about it because like I got to
figure this out and even though his back
was severely injured and he could barely
sit down properly and I was suffering
from insane allergies and we're both
operating in like fifty percent capacity
we struck out a way to make it make
sense add more order there was too much
chaos I needed more order and now I'm
happy again so chaos vs order where is
the line for you i'm really curious to
find out leave in the comments when you
feel overwhelmed with chaos or bored by
too much order let me know and i think
it could help inspire others as well who
are kind of facing those same challenges
i look forward to seeing your
discussions thank you so much for
watching continue to believe and i'll
see you soon